so jetzt geht es also los mit der
zweiten dritten lesung zur änderung des
bevölkerungs schütze selbst
egal wie man zur pandemie steht ich
glaube man kann eins sagen dass alle
kolleginnen und kollegen die letzten 13
monate mit dieser pandemie verbracht
haben mit einzelhändlern mit gastronomen
mit familien die verzweifelt waren weil
sie ihre kinder nicht mehr zur schule
schicken konnten und mit ganz ganz
vielen anderen die von der pandemie
betroffen worden sind aber ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen geht
mich bringt das manchmal um den schlaf
aber wenn es mich um den schlaf bringt
wenn ich nachts wach werden denke ich
nicht an einzelhändler und gastronomen
sondern ich denke an die menschen die
krank geworden sind würde ich denke an
die menschen die sterben und ich bin dem
bundestags er bundespräsidenten sehr
sehr dankbar dafür dass er diesen
menschen ein gesicht gegeben hat letzten
sonntag und ich
auch den medien sehr sehr dankbar dass
sie mit vielen sehr berührenden
geschichten dass auch unterstützt haben
und dass sie mal gezeigt haben wie es
ist wenn man unter longo wird leidet
welche einschränkungen das mit sich
bringt dass man enkelkinder interviewt
hat die ihre großeltern verloren haben
ja und auch alte menschen sind wertvoll
und das ist wertvoll das leben und das
ist verlust das ist leere
das ist trauer und bei jungen menschen
gilt das natürlich auch so und deswegen
meine damen und herren wir diskutieren
hier sehr viel über das grundgesetz ist
auch richtig so dass überhaupt nichts zu
kritisieren aber das grundgesetz hat
auch den artikel 2 absatz 2 da steht
drin jeder hat das recht auf leben und
körperliche unversehrtheit ihrer aktion
sogar aufgabe es ist unsere aufgabe als
abgeordnete des höchsten
verfassungsorgans dieses leben zu
schützen leben und gesundheit zu
schützen und das ist mein anspruch an
politik warum ich in die politik
gegangen bin weiß nicht wie es ihnen
geht und leben und gesundheit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
gefährdet und das hat auch sich nur der
professor marx von den intensivmediziner
angesagt sondern viele viele andere die
gesagt habt ihr müsst jetzt handeln wir
sind in einer situation wo nicht nur die
intensiv medizin überlastet ist wo das
gesamte gesundheitssystem überlastet ist
wir sind in einer situation wo zu viele
menschen krank werden und wo zu viele
menschen sterben und deswegen ist es
notwendig dass wir hier und heute
handeln und ich sage ganz bewusst wir
weil wir als deutscher bundestag gefragt
sind an diesen rednerpult haben dutzende
von rednerinnen und rednern gestanden
die gesagt haben der deutsche bundestag
muss die entscheidung treffen und nicht
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
der bundestagspräsident hat es uns ins
gebetbuch geschrieben
verfassungsrechtler haben es gesagt ich
glaube wir waren immer korrekt in der
vergangenheit aber jetzt ist die zeit
das der deutsche bundestag entscheidet
aber
wer immer sagt die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz kann sich
nicht einigen und die tag der auch zu
lange dann müssen wir sagen hier sind in
der lage uns zu einigen wir sind in der
lage auch kompromisse hinzubekommen
und wir haben als unions fraktion
zusammen mit unserem koalitionspartner
dieses gesetz im laufe des verfahrens
noch mal geändert um brücken zu bauen um
brücken zu bauen für all diejenigen die
kritisch sind aber über diese brücken
muss man jetzt auch hinüber gehen und
über diese brücken übergehen heißt
kompromisse zu schließen ich sage ganz
ehrlich wenn ich das gesetz hätte
alleine schließen können dann wäre es
härter und schärfer geworden aber das
gebietet der respekt auch vor der
mehrheitsbildung dass man da an der
einen oder anderen stelle diesen
kompromiss macht und kompromisse sind
kein zeichen von schwäche sondern stärke
in der pluralen demokratie und ich kann
nur jeden aufgerufen zu sagen es fehlt
mir vielleicht schwer an der einen oder
anderen stelle zuzustimmen aber dieses
gesetz ist es insgesamt wert das ist
heute durch den deutschen bundestag geht
denn wenn wir heute keine mehrheit
kriegen dann wird es kein gesetz geben
wenn es kein gesetz geben wird da gibt
es keine notstandsregierung und wenn es
keine notstands regelungen geben wird
dann werden menschen krank werden und
dann werden menschen sterben und dass
die afd bei diesen satz zwei damen und
herren das zeigt die fratze die diese
partei hier in diesem deutschen
bundestag hat
und jetzt wird gesagt hier und jetzt
wird gesagt wird gesagt ja das sprengt
den föderalismus nein ein dieses gesetz
ist vom hohen respekt vor dem
föderalismus geprägt weil nämlich weil
wir nämlich erst einsteigen nicht bei 10
das waren die inzidenz zahlen letzten
sommers als wir halt noch mal die täter
hatten nicht bei 35 was wir selber ins
infektionsschutzgesetz rein geschrieben
hat nicht als 50 was wir als notfall in
dieses infektionsschutzgesetz
reingeschrieben habe sondern bei 100
weil wir den ländern zutrauen dass sie
das unter 100 auch hinkriegen dass sie
regional differenziert mit
experimentierklausel mit test und vielen
vielen anderen sachen klarkommt aber 100
ist auch ganz unabhängig von den anderen
indikatoren so hoch dass eingegriffen
werden muss und dass wir eine
bundesweite regelung braucht meine damen
und herren und die schaffen wir heute
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und dann ist letzte woche weiß nicht ob
wahrheitswidrig oder versehentlich
behauptet worden dass dieses gesetz die
demokratie abschaffen
meine damen und herren nie war so viel
demokratie in der pandemie bekämpfung
für jetzt es ist so dass dieser deutsche
bundestag als höchstes verfassungsorgan
ein eindeutig entscheidet wenn passiert
dann muss diese folge da sein da gibt es
keinen spielraum für die bundesregierung
das ist demokratie und der zweite punkt
ist selbst bei der rechtsverordnung die
die bundesregierung erlassen kann ist es
so dass wir noch mal nachgebessert haben
und gesagt haben und diese
rechtsverordnung bedarf der zustimmung
des höchsten deutschen verfassungsorgane
des deutschen bundestages und wer da
sagt dass demokratie geschleift wird der
frage ich mich hat er dieses gesetz
gelesen hat das nicht gelesen oder
verbreitete er hier unwahrheiten um
aufzuhetzen und populistisch zu sein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen kann sich
über die ein oder andere maßnahme
durchaus streiten das ist auch gemacht
das ist überhaupt keine frage jetzt
wurde in der letzten debatte in der
ersten lesung gesagt ja aber da muss man
sich jetzt raus im natürlich muss man
sich heraus impfen
und wir werden auch besser entspannen
wird es gleich in seiner rede sagen aber
das wird für die nächsten wochen nicht
reichen da brauchen wir zusätzliche
maßnahmen und dann wird gesagt ja das
kriegen wir mit individuellen regionalen
test konzepten hin testen ist gut testen
ist wichtig testen ist richtig dass es
überhaupt keine frage
aber hier ist kein land bekannt was sich
aus hohen inzidenz zahlen runter
getestet hat am anfang stand immer der
lock down und dann wurde getestet und
regional gearbeitet
und deswegen brauchen wir diese
maßnahmen die wir jetzt haben und jetzt
ist es so das ist auch in der debatte
gefallen auch eben von herrn koch ich
glaube er hat es nicht so gemeint da ist
gesagt worden
aber weil das und das in diesem gesetz
schlimm ist oder in der ersten lesung
ist gesagt worden weil die
bundesregierung ich halte das für falsch
nicht genügend impfstoff beigebracht hat
weil nicht genügend getestet worden ist
können wir jetzt diesem gesetz nicht
zustimmen weil die arbeitgeber nicht
entsprechend belastet sind können wir
jetzt diesen gesetzlich zu stimmen herr
korte reden wollen sie bestrafen wir
wollen sie bestrafen wollen sie alle
bestrafen weil sie dieses gesetz nicht
vollumfänglich dann entsprechend
zustimmen können es geht nicht jetzt um
politische vorteile sondern es geht um
die gesundheit von den menschen in
diesem land und das sollte uns leiten
freundliche
und ich sage ihnen eins dieses gesetz
ist notwendig dieses gesetz muss hier im
deutschen bundestag verabschiedet werden
und nirgendwo anders dieses gesetz
respektiert die den föderalismus dieses
gesetz berücksichtigt dass wir mehr
impfen und dass wir mehr testen und
deswegen ist es begrenzt auf den 30 06
und dieses gesetz ist nach unserer
festen auffassung nach feste auffassung
des bundesinnenministers der
bundesministerien für justiz und
verbraucherschutz auch verfassungsgemäß
und deswegen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich habe eine herzliche bitte
ich habe wirklich eine herzliche bitte
wir werden und das wird jetzt sparen
gleich noch erläutern mit einer
unglaublichen dynamik im bereich impfen
in diesem sommer aus dieser pandemie
rauskommen und viel viel normalität
wieder zurückbekommen aber bis dahin ist
es unsere entscheidung hier im deutschen
bundestag wie viele menschen erkranken
und vielleicht auch sterben und deswegen
deswegen kann ich sie nur um eins bitten
dieses gesetz ist ein gesetz fürs leben
dieses gesetz beruht auf artikel 2
absatz 2 des grundgesetzes und bitte
stimmen sie diesem gesetz zu stimmen sie
für das leben und haben dann auch die
entsprechende entscheidung auch wenn es
schwer fällt in der zweiten und dritten
lesung ich habe wirklich die ganz ganz
ganz herzliche bitte schützen sie leben
stimmen sie zu herzlichen dank
[Applaus]